IS "THE FIVE."
>> IT'S THE RESULT AGAINST THE
RADICAL IDENTITY POLITICS AGENDA
ALL ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
>> REMEMBER THAT NEW JERSEY
SCHOOL DISTRICT THAT YANKED ALL
HOLIDAY NAMES OFF THE CALENDAR
TO AVOID HURT FEELINGS?
THEY JUST REVERSED COURSE.
PARENTS SAY THEY ARE BEING
SMEARED AS RIGHT WING FANATICS
AFTER CALLING OUT THE SCHOOL
BOARD.
>> AFTER YOU OVERTURN THIS
IDIOTIC DECISION, YOU WILL
RESIGN.
ALL OF YOU WILL RESIGN TODAY.
>> YOU MANAGED TO WAKE UP THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY OF RANDOLPH.
THIS IS A FLAG POINT.
WE DRAW THE LINE IN THE SAND.
YOU HAVE OVERREACHED.
>> IN LOWDEN COUNTY, VIRGINIA,
THE EPICENTER OF THE PUSH BACK
AGAINST CRITICAL RACE THEORY THE
SCHOOL BOARD THERE IS MEETING
FOR THE FINAL TIME THIS YEAR
TONIGHT.
PARENTS TELLING SCHOOL OFFICIALS
THEY WON'T BE SILENCED.
>> THIS IS ABOUT A PARENTS'
MOVEMENT TO TAKE BACK OUR
SCHOOLS.
TO GET A SEAT AT THE TABLE WITH
HOW OUR SCHOOLS ARE RUN.
YOU HAVE SPECIAL INTERESTS.
YOU HAVE ACTIVISTS.
THAT'S THE ONLY GROUP THEY SEEM
TO LISTEN TO, WHEREAS PARENTS
SHOW UP EVERY DAY TO TRY AND
MAKE THEIR VOICES HEARD AND WE
GET IGNORED.
>> IN COLORADO, A MAYOR THERE
TRIED TO SUSPEND THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS DUE TO UNSPECIFIED
REASONS.
THE ATTENDEES RESCINDED IT
ANYWAY.
>> YOU VIEW DIRECT AND INDIRECT
THREATS --
[INAUDIBLE]
WE WILL NOT BE DOING THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE DURING COUNCIL AND
BOARD OF TRUSTEE MEETINGS.
>> WE AS A BOARD COLLECTIVELY
DECIDED IT WOULD BE DONE.
>> THIS IS NOT UP FOR DISCUSSION
AT THIS MOMENT.
>> OH, NOT UP FOR DISCUSSION,
DANA.
DO YOU REALLY THINK IT WAS
DIVISIVE, THE PLEDGE, MAYBE ONE
PERSON SAID THEY DIDN'T LIKE IT.
>> MAYBE THEY GOT A TWEET AND A
PANIC.
WHEN EVERYBODY ATTENDING THE
MEETING STANDS UP AND SAYS THE
PLEDGE ANYWAY, AT THE END, THE
MODERATOR, HE SAYS, THAT'S OUT
OF ORDER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I THINK THAT WE'RE SHOWING
EXAMPLES ALL ACROSS AMERICA,
FIRST OF ALL, OF WHAT IT'S LIKE
TO ACTUALLY ATTEND A SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING.
I WAS TALKING TO A GUY THE OTHER
DAY, AT ONE OF THE RANDOLPH
MEETINGS, I HAVE NEVER BEEN TO A
SCHOOL BOARD MEETING IN MY LIFE
AND NOW THEY HAVE GONE TO
SEVERAL OF THEM AND YOU SEE
AMERICAN PARENTS ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SAYING, WAIT, WHAT'S
GOING ON IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT
AND SHOWING UP AT SCHOOL BOARD
MEETINGS, WHICH I THINK IS VERY
HEALTHY.
YOU WANT PEOPLE TO BE MORE
ENERGIZED, ENGAGED, AND POSSIBLY
USEE SOMEBODY LIKE IAN PRYOR, I
DON'T KNOW, YOU CAN IMAGINE
BECAUSE HE'S AWOKE THEN MOVEMENT
IN LOWDEN COUNTY, VIRGINIA,
PERHAPS HE'LL RUN FOR SCHOOL
BOARD.
ASK YOURSELF, WOULD YOU WANT TO
RUN?
AND ACTUALLY GETTING INTO THE
ARENA AS ONE OF THE IMPORTANT
THINGS.
THE AVERAGE AMERICAN IS MORE
PATRIOTIC, MORE MODERATE, MUCH
LESS PARTISAN THAN ANY MEDIA
CONVERSATION WOULD HAVE YOU
THINK.
>> AND THAT'S WHERE THE ACTION
IS, GREG.
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
>> GREG: LOOK.
I'M A LITTLE PESSIMISTIC.
I THINK IT'S TOO LATE.
THESE -- WE HAVE THREE EXAMPLES
HERE.
WHEN YOU HAVE THREE EXAMPLES,
YOU HAVE A SEGMENT.
RIGHT?
IT'S LIKE IF THERE WERE TWO WE
WOULDN'T HAVE DONE THIS BUT WE
HAD THREE AND I APPLAUD IT, AND
THESE PEOPLE ARE BRAVE BUT I
THINK IT'S TOO LATE.
I THINK THE INDOCTRINATION IS
PRESENT IN OUR CULTURE, OUR
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY,
ACADEMIA, AND ALSO, OUR
CORPORATIONS.
HAVE YOU SEEN A TYPICAL HR EMAIL
LATELY, WE WON'T MENTION IT BUT
THE LANGUAGE IS DIRECTLY LIFTED
FROM ACADEMIC IDENTITY POLITICS'
LEXICON.
IT IS EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK.
I DON'T THINK I HAVE SEEN
ANYTHING SPREAD SO FAST IN MY
LIFE AND IT PREYS UPON THESE
TWO -- THE TWO FLAWS OF HUMAN
NATURE.
ONE OF THEM IS FEAR.
PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED OF BEING
OSTRACIZED, OR LOSING THEIR JOBS
OR BOTH, WHICH IS WHY YOU SEE
STUDENTS PARROTING THIS WOKE
BABBLE FROM THEIR TEACHERS.
YOU SEE CORPORATE EXECUTIVES
EMBRACING THE DIVERSITY
PLATITUDES, AND WHY ENTERTAINERS
ARE SO DESPERATELY WAVING THE
BLM FLAG.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY WOULD RATHER
YOU NOT LOOK IN THEIR PAST FOR
SEXUAL INDISCRETIONS.
THAT'S FEAR.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT FEAR
CAUSES PEOPLE TO BLEND IN,
RIGHT?
THIS IS WHY HUMAN BEINGS IMITATE
EACH OTHER'S BEHAVIOR.
THEY DON'T WANT TO STAND OUT.
THAT WAS A METHOD FOR SURVIVAL.
IF YOU DON'T WOKE THE AFTER YOU
THEN YOU PARROT THE WOKE.
CAMOUFLAGE.
THAT'S WHY I BELIEVE THAT THIS
STUFF IS SPREADING, AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW TO STOP IT BECAUSE,
FEAR AND JUST WANTING TO BELONG
IS LETTING IT HAPPEN AND IT
HAPPENING ALL AROUND US.
THAT'S WHY THESE THINGS -- I'M
GLAD THEY ARE AT THE SCHOOL
BOARD AND MAYBE THAT'S WHERE THE
FIGHT HAS TO HAPPEN BECAUSE IT'S
VISUAL AND PEOPLE WILL BE
PERSUADED BY IT BUT I THINK
ABOUT, ARE WE GOING TO HAVE A
FIGHT WITH OUR CORPORATE HR?
NO.
ARE PEOPLE GOING TO FIGHT THE
PRINCIPALS, AT COLLEGES?
ARE THEY -- I DON'T KNOW.
>> OUR HR DEPARTMENT DOES A BANG
UP JOB.
>> GREG: I WAS THINKING OF IT AS
A GENERIC.
>> I THINK YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT
CORPORATE AMERICA.
THEY HAVE SURRENDERED TO THE
WOKE PEOPLE BUT I DISAGREE ON
THE SCHOOL BOARD FRONT.
I THINK PARENTS ARE VERY
OUTRAGED, AND THEY ARE NOT GOING
TO PUT UP WITH IT ANYMORE AND
THAT'S WHERE THEY ARE GETTING
TRACTION AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SHOWING THIS.
>> AND THAT'S WHERE THE CHANGE
BEGINS TO HAPPEN BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING IN HR AT
THESE MAJOR CORPORATIONS, WHO
ARE MAKING MARKETING DECISIONS,
PURELY FOR THE FRINGED LEFT,
THEY WERE INDOCTRINATED THROUGH
COLLEGE AND THAT'S WHO IS
WORKING IN THESE CORPORATIONS.
SO IF YOU START EVEN AT THE
GRADE SCHOOL AND HIGH SCHOOL
LEVEL, BUT TO DANA'S POINT, MOST
AMERICANS ARE GO ALONG GET ALONG
KIND OF FOLKS WHO REALLY TRY TO
AVOID CONTROVERSY.
THEY WORK THEIR ASS'S OFF.
THEY ARE DEALING WITH FRIENDS,
FAMILY, CHURCH, AND MAYBE THEY
WANT TO GO FISHING ONCE EVERY
FEW MONTHS.
THEY DON'T HAVE TIME FOR THIS
NONSENSE BUT ALL IT TAKES IS ONE
SMALL GROUP OF JERKS TO SET THEM
OFF.
I CALL IT THE REVERSE DOMINO
THEORY SO INSTEAD OF FALLING
DOWN ONE BY ONE, YOU HAVE -- IT
JUST TAKES ONE PERSON TO STAND
UP.
ONE OUTRAGED PARENT.
OR CITIZEN SPEAKING UP, AND THEN
10 MORE WILL STAND UP BECAUSE
THEY FEEL SUPPORTED, AND THEY
GET LOUD.
AND THAT'S HOW CHANGE HAPPENS.
AND THIS IS NOT -- THEY ARE
TRYING TO PAINT IT LIKE THESE
ARE CONSERVATIVE PARENTS.
CONSERVATIVE INDIVIDUALS.
NO WAY.
YOU START TO LOOK AT WHO A LOT
OF THESE PEOPLE ARE.
THEY ARE ACROSS THE SPECTRUM OF
RACES AND SOCIOECONOMIC GROUPS
BUT THEY SEE THEIR CHILDREN
BEING INDOCTRINATED INTO HATE.
>> GREG: YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
AN EDUCATIONAL TEA PARTY.
>> THAT'S WHERE THE ACTION IS.
RICHARD, I ASSUME YOU AGREE WITH
EVERYTHING WE JUST SAID?
>> I SPENT MY AFTERNOON READING
SOME OF THESE CRITICAL RACE
BILLS BECAUSE I THINK READING IS
FUNDAMENTAL.
>> NEVER HEARD OF THAT.
>> I WAS DISMAYED BECAUSE NOT
ONLY ARE THESE BILLS POORLY
WORDED AND VAGUE IN THEIR
WRITING BUT SOME OF THESE BILLS
MAKE LITERALLY NO SENSE.
THE BILL IN IOWA BANS SEXUAL,
SLAVERY --
>> THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> HAVE YOU READ THE BILL?
>> I WILL BET -- YOU WILL
FIND -- A BILL THAT SAYS WE'LL
NOT TEACH SLAVERY IN THE SCHOOL
IN IOWA.
>> IT SAYS IT'S PROHIBITED IN
THE CURRICULUM.
IT'S PROHIBITED IN THE
CURRICULUM.
IT'S IN SECTION 5.
>> SLAVERY IN --
>> ALLOW ME -- [CROSS TALKING]
[LAUGHTER]
>> IT'S ACTUALLY WOVEN INTO THE
BILL IT WOULD HAVE BEEN ON THE
FRONT PAGE OF EVERY NEWSPAPER.
>> IT ACTUALLY WAS IN IOWA BUT
BACK TO WHAT I WAS SAYING.
>> JOB ANY --
>> SEXISM, SLAVERY, RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION INCLUDING TOPICS
RELATED TO THE ENACTMENT AND
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS RESULTING IN
SEXISM, RACIAL OPPRESSION AND
SEGREGATION.
THAT'S LIKE HALF OF AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> THAT HISTORY IS BANNED IN
IOWA.
>> THAT MEANS IF YOU'RE A
STUDENT, A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
IN IOWA AND YOU'RE STUDYING FOR
THE AMERICAN AP HISTORY EXAM,
YOU'RE LIKELY TO FAIL BECAUSE
HALF OF THESE TOPICS WON'T BE
TAUGHT.
>> FROM 1776 --
>> 1965 IN IOWA.
>> ACTUALLY, IF YOU READ THE
WORDING, THEY REALLY COULDN'T
TEACH 1976 BECAUSE ABIGAIL
ADAMS' LETTER TO THE HUSBAND --
WOULD BE ILLEGAL.
>> THEY DON'T EVEN START IN
1776.
>> I'M TELLING YOU WHAT THE BILL
SAYS.
>> THIS IS PART OF THE PROBLEM.
>> WHICH IS PART OF THE PROBLEM.
>> IF YOU ATTACK CRITICAL RACE
THEORY AND ACTUALLY NOT TALK
ABOUT WHAT'S BEING TAUGHT IN
CLASS WHICH IS THE TRUTH ABOUT
AMERICAN HISTORY WE HAVE THIS
DILEMMA WHICH IS VAGUELY, POORLY
WRITTEN, QUICKLY WRITTEN BILL,
THAT MAKES ABSOLUTELY POSITIVELY
NO SENSE.
>> WE'LL FIND OUT THE TRUTH
ABOUT THE BILL I